vous ce pompier agressé par une femme et
sauf qu'aujourd'hui il ya une polémique
à l'envers on l'avocat considère qu'il
ya eu un acharnement médiatique petit
récap on en parle juste après
c'est l'image qui a marqué ces
manifestations du 1er mai le week-end
dernier
une jeune femme qui agressent
physiquement un pompier alors qu'ils
tentent d'éteindre un incendie de rue
cette militante d'extrême gauche de 38
ans connu pour avoir déjà manifesté lors
du convoi des libertés ou pendant le
mouvement des gilet jaune a été
interpellée et mise en garde à vue si
lundi sur notre plateau son mari s'était
désolidarisé de son geste et le jeune
aujourd'hui son avocate a dénoncé une
vindicte médiatique contre sa cliente je
pense que les réquisitions de détention
provisoire ne faisait que hector à cette
folie qui s'emparerait autour de ce
dossier alors conquis agressé le 1er mai
comprenez vous que les avocats de
l'accusé parle d'un acharnement
médiatique alors est ce que vous
comprenez
alors il ya un oui c est un drogué
hominem pas pour ça il faut pas qu'on
fasse le procès avant le procès non mais
les faits sont évidemment extrêmement
grave ça c'est pas un débat en revanche
ce que dénoncent les mets mes avocats de
leur cliente c'est que le parquet aurait
fait fuiter des à son identité aux
médias ce qui représente une violation
une seule enquête déjà première chose
ensuite il reproche aussi aux policiers
de l'avoir entre on a reçus en avait
reçu sur marie n'importe quoi mais
d'avoir diffusé oui mais ça s'explique
en large son mari parce qu'on a connu
son identité avant et que ça a été
révélée par le parquet mais ne sont bien
sûr que si il reproche également aux
policiers de l'avoir entre guillemets
harcelé pendant sa garde à vue en lui
montrant des tweets l'insultant et la
menaçant pendant sa garde à vue voilà
est par ailleurs tiens à le préciser
c'est une femme qui a une vie
personnelle extrêmement compliquée qui a
été victime dune de menaces de mort et
d'une tentative de meurtre dans un
contexte familial enfin ils trouvaient
ça
n'excuse en rien ce qu'elle a fait ses
avocats ils doivent la défendre et il
dénonce un acharnement médiatique
évidemment ce qu'elle a fait est
extrêmement grave elle va être rejugé
pour sage explique juste qu'ils
reprochent au parquet alors on va
regarder la vidéo justement
insupportable je ne comprends pas que
l'on puisse s'attaquer aux pompiers de
toute façon qu'ils sont là pour nous et
nous sauver la pole et là il faut juste
dire mais les pompiers radi cité là pour
éteindre un feu pourquoi parce que les
les gaz là qui sait man là les fumées et
ses preuves à es6 et asphyxient
absolument chez les voisins ou les
personnes âgées qui sont dans l'immeuble
d'à côté c'est terrible c'est
insupportable estime la boisson mashala
aux personnes âgées daniela les voilà
mais moi je n'en peux plus je n'en peux
plus depuis deux jours alors je précise
juste que je suis triste pour les
enfants cette femme a deux enfants en
bas âge donc évidemment ça c'est triste
mais on est en train de faire du
bourreau la victime et c'est
insupportable depuis deux jours je
n'entends que ça elle a un cdi elle s
est belle et pas violente d'habitude
elle a deux enfants allaient mener
campagne oui tout à fait mais voilà mais
moi en tout cas c'est la petite musique
que j'entends guillaume vient de la
refaire alors moi je voudrais juste dire
le pompier dont personne ne parle il a
24 ans tous les matins il se lève
excusez moi je suis parce que mon cousin
était pompier et je sais je me souviens
de sa mère qui était inquiète tout le
temps tous les jours de voir partir son
fils pour sauver des vies pour prendre
des risques et ça voilà le compte y est
on n'en parle jamais annonc loi je dis
bravo aux pompiers et il faudrait qu'on
parle un peu plus de la victime que du
bourreau
honnêtement
d'ailleurs on annonce que daniel moreau
à faire une tournée des casernes
mais pas que pour les finitions
les pompiers mais elle s'expose et donc
tu peux pas dire que c'est la police qui
a donné son identité aux médias parce
qu'on voit sa tête enfin aucun moment
donné quand tu veux pas qu'on voit ta
tête tu te mets pas comme ça après je
suis désolé mais enfin oui daniel tata
tu as totalement raison en vrai je suis
ils regardent pas qu'elle voulait pas
sagement regarde les bottes le casque la
tenue qu'elle a
quand même un autre problème c'est qu'on
a de plus en plus de mal à cause de ça à
recruter chez les pompiers chaque au jeu
ça vient certes il faut quand même
savoir ce que ce garçon a 24 ans et de
grade 1 et touche 1480 euros par mois
donc en l'occurrence si on n'arrive plus
à recruter de gens si on n'arrive plus à
voir des gens qui nous défendre nous
aident et qui nous aide dans cette
mission de service public ça devient une
catastrophe aussi il faut en faire un
exemple c'est bien que médiatisée et si
on en parlait vous avez des poursuites
pour violences sur personne chargée
d'une mission de service public outrage
rébellion participation à un groupement
en vue de commettre des violences ou
dégradations lors de manifestations et
entrave à l'arrivée des secours destinés
à combattre assiste dangereux pour les
personnes oui c'est ça oui parce qu
attendu que ça dans les 75000 quand les
agents de police l'ont saisie juste
après ça c'est une agression violente
elle les a insultés leur a filé d'écouté
du nouvion avait des chaussures est de
contrebalancer on a élargi son mari sur
le plateau qui est bien qu'on va pour
extrêmement digne ou et le cias
également enfin s'est excusé pour sa fin
après oui je vous sens énervé mais quand
même vous écoute et qui n'auraient pas
fait on
s'est battu on regarde chacun s'exprime
à sa façon il ya des gens qui
s'expriment en chantant il y en a qui
s'exprime en car même à chanter genton
c'est peut-être mieux que c'est après
chacun est libre de son choix aussi
casser du pompier excusez-moi s'annoncer
la vie des autres ça je suis pas
d'accord pas mal mais sans que je ne
sois d'accord donc ce geste là je ne
tout à l'heure la république c'est nous
c'est l'ensemble des services publics
auxquels tout le monde adhère
aujourd'hui tout le monde doit se
rassembler non mais moi je soutiens
entièrement les pompiers et le jeu je ne
suis pas d'accord et puis voilà les les
avocats dont vous parlez guillaume se
sont exprimés pour tenter d'expliquer
cet acharnement médiatique parce que les
réquisitions de détention provisoire ne
faisait que hector à cette folie qui
s'emparerait autour de ce dossier nous
avons hâte de pouvoir donner des
explications sur l'ensemble des
infractions qui sont reprochés et de
pouvoir pour un certain nombre d'entre
elles qui est d une relaxe une plainte
va également être déposée par rapport à
la façon dont elle enquête a été menée
puisque sa mine et madame que sa vie
privée soit exposé que son visage soit
menée en pâture à l'ensemble de la
population française
mais c'est ça ne nage et pas de
compassion je le reconnais là je suis
très choquée de ce qu'elle avait moi je
défends les pompiers ce sont des gens
formidables sont nos héros ainsi on
commence à frapper les pompiers la
police finit un savoir rire c'est que là
je suis désolé désolé navré aille au
moment des faits gars aient un accès
allez on va mettre ça tu as lu ça
n'explique pas tout et ça va mais ça
aurait été plus recevable que de dire ça
je dépose plainte non mais ok on va
suivre ça va faire de prêt pour savoir
comment est née la justice parce que
forcément savoir en faire un exemple de
ce rapport que lorsque ça va être un peu
compliqué pour la dame par où commencer